Saudi Arabia has this very soft
technique for dealing with terrorists
they're very proud of that I tell them
it's not really so different from the
Betty Ford Clinic you know it's a sort
of rehab for terrorists there's been
quite a lot of publicity about it and
it's slightly exaggerated publicity
because the real hardcore terrorists
refused to take part in the rehab there
are about 10 15 % of the guys they've
caught from al-qaeda who want nothing to
do and they hated the Saudi government
for they hate it now and they're not
going to sit round in therapy circles
discussing their problems in some ways
it's been picked up from America in
other ways again it goes back to the
Islamic Golden Age I mean the first
mental hospitals in the in the world
were created at Arab countries with
people like Avicenna having the idea of
the healthy mind in the healthy body at
a time when in in Europe mad people were
getting thrown into ponds with their
arms and legs bound because they were
considered as being possessed by the
devil Saudi Arabia in those days Arabia
was treating mental mentally damaged
people with with kindness and that's the
tradition they're trying now it's not
just therapy they do they do practical
things these these ex extremists when
it's felt they've moved along enough to
go out into the world
they're supplied with a car they're
supplied with a job and they're also
most practically more supplied with the
wife because if you're a young Saudi
it'll cost you about 18 to 20 thousand
dollars to get married that's what this
isn't the party this is the bride price
you have to pay to get a wife if you're
a young Saudi and lots of kids can't
afford that so the government pays for
these young extremists to to get wives
and I you know I'm gonna I know a number
of them and I got one particular friend
he did time in Guantanamo he came back
got his car nice Toyota nice apartment
in Jeddah nice wife but after several
years his wife hadn't produced any
children so they went back to the
government and they arranged the
fertility treatment so now she's
producing children because this is not
just charity this is based on the belief
that you've got to give these young men
a stake in society and it's been
reasonably successful although you know
al-qaeda is so cunning a number of these
young men having been through the
process have then fled Saudi Arabia
reappeared in Yemen which is in the
South like a sort of Afghanistan on the
southern border when so remote and
mountainous there are camps and that
sort of thing where these jihadis train
and the only difference between Yemen
and Afghanistan is that Yemen is in the
same mobile-phone zone as Saudi Arabia
which means that the the mothers and
fathers can phone up the kids and say
come on you know you're disgracing the
family it's time to come home now that's
another element of this Saudi therapy
they involve the family I mean in the
West most 18 year-olds can't wait to get
away from their parents in Saudi Arabia
men of 30 or 40 are scared stiff of
their mothers and indeed of their
fathers and so just last a couple of
months ago a few months ago in August
one very clever member of al Qaeda who
been through the program gone there and
has said that gone down to Yemen phoned
up the minister the prince was in charge
of the rehab program and said I'm sorry
sir I'd like to come back
can you send a plane to collect me and
so they sent a plane down to pick him up
it was Ramadan time in Jeddah and so
there were all these gatherings and he
came to Ramadan he embraced the Prince
he said I got another friend down there
who would like to come back can we go in
a separate room and talk about this and
I got a mobile phone because the
security guys tried to take the mobile
phone off him he said no sir you know he
won't answer
he'll only answer this number if he
recognizes it so they went in a room he
picked up the mobile phone and called
his friend handed it to the Prince the
Prince listened to the phone and heard
all this cheering and laughing and
jeering at the other end and at that
moment the guy with him blew up because
it was a plot that al-qaeda had devised
and those are supposed to be the last
things the Prince heard but
unfortunately the well the ingenious way
they'd hidden the explosive was to
insert the inspo civ up his rectum
inside him that's the way he got through
on security checks and happily human
physiology has made the the central
girdle the pelvic girdle very strong so
as he stood there the pelvic girdle
contained the blast the blast went down
the blast went out there was some very
graphic photographs in the Saudi papers
of these body parts sprayed all over the
ceiling and the prints to this day has
lived to tell the tale but that's a sort
of battle that's going on I mean even as
we speak
I've tried dealing with some real
fundamentalists and you tried talking to
them and they just look away they they
sort of don't acknowledge you as being a
human being and I suppose at moments
like that I've got a sort of sense of
the chilling indifference to human life
that inspires the members of al-qaeda
and the the extremists but on the whole
you know most Saudis I know deplore and
are embarrassed by Osama bin Laden and
you know no III have to say I feel quite
safe in Saudi Arabia